este problema dice 16 onzas líquidas más
tres pintas más cuatro cuartas es igual
a cuántos galones ya platicamos de
pintas cuartas y galones pero no hemos
platicado de onzas líquidas hemos
platicado acerca de onzas pero las onzas
y las onzas líquidas son cosas muy
distintas déjame contarte por qué
empezamos con las onzas líquidas las
onzas líquidas líquidas
y las onzas líquidas son unidades de
volumen le voy a poner aquí volumen vale
son como las pintas las cuartas y los
galones por otro lado las onzas las
onzas son unidades pero de peso de peso
son como las libras vale y bueno para
hacer las cosas un poco más fáciles o
quizás un poco más confusas resulta que
una onza líquida de agua así a
temperatura y presión estándar pesan más
o menos una onza una onza de las de aquí
abajo una de éstas de hecho pesa un
poquito más vale bueno con esto en mente
ahora déjame darte las conversiones
entre onzas líquidas y estas otras
unidades
empezamos con tasas resulta que tenemos
ocho onzas líquidas 8 onzas líquidas
líquidas lo voy a abreviar así por taza
portas vale y como al juntar dos tazas
tenemos una pinta tenemos que hay 16 16
onzas
líquidas líquidas por tinta por tinta
vale ahora si recordamos que 16 onzas de
las de acá 16 onzas son una libra una
libra entonces tenemos algo interesante
tenemos que una pinta de agua pesa lo
mismo que una libra bueno de hecho ha
pesado un poquito más que una lima vale
bueno esto está interesante pero ahora
sí vamos a pasar a resolver el problema
vale entonces lo que vamos a hacer es ir
convirtiendo las unidades sumar las
convertirlas y sumar las y así
sucesivamente entonces empecemos con 16
onzas líquidas y vamos a pasar las
pintas usando esto de acá vale entonces
si usamos esto tenemos que 16 onzas
líquidas a ver voy a tomar el color azul
entonces 16 onzas líquidas
líquidas
las queremos convertir en tintas
entonces hay que voltear esta conversión
verdad tenemos que multiplicar por pinta
y tenemos que dividir entre 16 16
onzas líquidas líquidas vale y entonces
al hacer esta conversión estas ondas
líquidas se cancelan con estas el 16 con
el 16 se hace un 116 entre 16 es 1 así
que nos queda igual a una pinta que
bueno eso ya lo sabíamos verdad ya
sabíamos que una pinta era igual a 16
onzas líquidas pero bueno aquí lo
hicimos con el método de conversión
entonces estas onzas líquidas estas 16
onzas líquidas las podemos pensar como
una pinta ahora podemos sumar esta pinta
con estas tres pintas de modo que en
total hasta acá tenemos cuatro pintas
y ahora tenemos que convertir estas
pintas a cuartas para poder sumar pintas
con cuartas vale entonces déjame pasar
aquí abajo las cuatro pintas voy a
cambiar de color a un color rojo
entonces ahora tenemos cuatro pintas
tintas y lo que queremos hacer es
dividir entre pintas entre pintas y
queremos que arriba nos queden cuartas
cuartas entonces recordamos la
conversión entre pintas y cuartas
resulta que dos pintas son una cuarta
entonces aquí voy a poner dos pintas son
una cuarta cancelamos pintas con pintas
cuatro entre 200 así que aquí nos quedan
dos cuartos dos cuartas vale entonces
estas cuatro pintas son dos cuartas
dos cuartas así que ahora podemos sumar
estas dos cuartas con estas cuatro
cuartas nos quedan seis cuartas en total
seis cuartas
y finalmente tenemos que convertir
cuartos a galones porque la respuesta
final nos la piden en galones déjame
tomar el color naranja entonces ahora
tenemos seis cuartas cuartas y la
conversión está fácil de acordarse
verdad porque cuatro cuartas son un
galón
entonces queremos dividir entre cuartas
para que se cancelen martha's arriba
queremos que nos quede galón
bueno galones entonces cuatro cuartos es
un galón y realizamos la conversión
cuartas con cuartos de cancela nos queda
seis cuartos de galón seis cuartos de
galón
que podemos simplificar dividiendo el
numerador y denominador entre 2 nos
queda tres medios de galón de galón y
esta de aquí ya sería una respuesta
bastante aceptable pero se puede
expresar también como una fracción mixta
sale tenemos tres medios de galón 3
entre 2 es 1 y sobra 1 entonces esto es
1 con un medio de galón
galo vale entonces el resultado de sumar
todas estas unidades de volumen es un
galón y medio